- And I've said this
many, many times.
LeBron James is a
basketball player,
he's not that smart.
Listen to him talk.
Go read his Twitter
feed, his Instagram.
He can barely spell
but y'all think
this guy is some kind
of thought leader,
public intellectual, whatever.
And then the number one
thing 'cause I you know,
his lack of grammar
and all that.
I can almost deal with that
but what the media won't deal
with is that Muhammad Ali,
whether we like the
Nation of Islam or not.
He was connected and
controlled by a religious sect
and Elijah Muhammad, Malcolm X,
whether we like them or not.
Very smart people.
Ahead of the curve.
They control, Muhammad Ali
said what they told him to say
and did what they told
him to do at that time.
LeBron James ain't
connected to nobody but Nike
and Phil Knight.
Phil Knight is not Elijah
Muhammad or Malcolm X
and so whose, whose advice?
Adam Mendelsohn or, and
I know Adam Mendelsohn.
The PR guy that works around
but he ain't Malcolm X
or Elijah Muhammad.
Expecting any of
these, these athletes
can barely keep up
with they baby mamas.
How the hell they gonna keep up
with what's going on in
the rest of the world?
It's, we keep putting
them in this position.
We keep, oh who gonna
be the next Muhammad Ali
and we have to accept,
those days are gone.
(calm music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a sports analyst,
a culture critic
and host of the fairly new
show, "Fearless" on BlazeTV.
Jason Whitlock, welcome to
round two on The Rubin Report.
- I thought this was round
three but maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe you know, your
interviews are so long
they just feel like two rounds.
- Oh he's starting
it with a hook.
I'm pretty sure
this is round two.
- Well.
- I think it's round two.
- Oh my.
Well I got another
hook shot I'm about to throw.
- We shall,
you're the sports guy.
You guys love stats.
- Yeah.
- You sports people.
- Let me throw another jab
before you get started.
- Yeah.
- I just want everybody
to know watching at home.
A month ago or three weeks ago,
I asked Dave to come on my show,
to consent to an interview.
Dave puts me off,
"Oh I'm on vacation.
"I'm doing this,
I'm doing that."
And somehow I end
up on Dave's show
before he comes on my show.
Dave doesn't say
anything about you know,
I'll return the favor
anything like that.
Just Dave being Dave.
Well I guess so.
- Well.
- Here I am.
- I just wanted to
get through this one,
make sure it works out okay.
We're off to a good start
and then I'll gladly
swing by over there.
- All right, all right.
Well I'm probably gonna
talk about the stuff
I wanna talk with you about.
I'm gonna probably
talk about it to now
and it'll be over.
We'll just run a replay of
this interview on my show
but anyway go ahead.
I'm sorry, I'm gonna shut
up and listen to you.
It's your show.
- I know we'll have,
I have a feeling we'll find
some other things to talk about
but there's actually a ton
I wanna talk to you about
because when I had you
on and I'm pretty sure
it's only been once but
when I had you on in studio,
in LA a couple years back,
it's probably a good
three years ago already.
I mean time flies,
especially these days.
You know it sort
of felt like sports
was in the midst of
this weird meltdown
but it didn't feel like
it had fully melted down
and the racialization
of everything
and the gender and
football is gay
and all of the stuff
that is out there now.
So I guess my first
question really is,
what's your general take
on what has happened
to sports in general in
the last couple of years?
I think I told you that I
don't watch anything anymore.
I do not watch professional
sports anymore.
That's very sad to me.
I just can't take it anymore.
- Dave, I just had
this discussion on
my show on Wednesday
about, because the NFL
right now is bragging about,
"Hey, week one ratings were up
seven percent over a year ago
"and the NFL is back and
look at the TV ratings."
And what I am arguing is like,
the NFL in particular is
America's comfort food
and America is in desperate
need of comfort right now
because of COVID
and because of the racial
meltdown we've had.
We're looking for
anything that reminds us
of the way things used to be
and so I think the initial
kind of rush back to
sports and football
and filling up stadiums
and let's have fun,
I think that's what's happening.
People are looking, they
want some nostalgia.
They want some comfort.
I do think and I argued
this on Wednesday
and Uncle Jimmy and the guest
we had on, Dennis Evans.
They both pushed
back against me.
But I do think the passion for
sports has waned and faded.
I see it in myself.
I don't like or
respect the athletes
the way that I used
to and it's never,
it's never that I used
to think these guys
were the smartest
guys on the planet
but I also didn't think
they were the dumbest guys
on the planet or the
easiest to control
or totally controled by
groupthink and social media.
I didn't think they
were frauds and phonies
who were just willing
to say and do anything
to stay in the good
graces of social media
and the elite overlords and
that's what I think now.
So I still watch the sports.
I don't feel as good about
the athletes and eventually
and I made this analogy.
It's like the old B.B. King
song, "The Thrill Is Gone".
And sometimes when you're
ending a relationship,
you go through this part where
you're not quite separated.
You're still living
in the same house,
you're still going
through the motions
but everybody knows it's over
and that's kind of how I feel
about professional sports.
I still watch, I still somewhat.
I love them, I love the games.
But the passion for the
athletes just isn't the same
as it used to be and
eventually I'll just spend less
and less time with sports.
- On a personal note, how
much does that suck for you?
I mean not only is this your job
and you got into this
stuff because you love it.
I mean I was never
a sports analyst
but I grew up watching the
same games you were watching,
loving that stuff
and it kind of sucks.
When I'm flipping on YouTube
and I'm watching old NBA
games when it wasn't political
and then they show me a new one.
I'm just like, no I
just don't wanna do it
and it kind of sucks.
- No it sucks big time Dave
because for someone like me who,
there's two things that
have shaped my worldview.
The church my grandmother
and mother raised me in
and football and playing sports
'cause in high school I
played, track and field.
Played a little basketball,
intermural whatever.
Played foot,
I was into sports and the
values taught in sports
and the values
taught in my church,
there was great synergy
and alignment between them.
I'm looking at sports
betray all of those values
and it irritates
the heck out of me.
It bothers me immensely
and so, this sucks.
To see something this
central to your core beliefs
completely pivot and give
into Marxism and you know,
authoritarian, everybody
must get the vax
or you face these
harsh penalties of.
I just don't like any
of it and yeah it just,
and it sucks big time.
- So the newest thing,
speaking of the vax
in the last couple days now.
The NBA has reached
a deal somehow,
even though they have
over 100 employees
that the players will not
have to be vaccinated.
I don't understand how
that makes any sense.
I'm not for mandating
vaxes so just you know that
but they've gotten
this exemption
but it appears that the
people who go to the games
will have to be vaccinated.
Now I'm fairly
certain NBA players
might sweat on each
other, spit on each other.
Do they have some sort of
protections we don't know about?
- They don't, this sounds
similar to what the NFL.
You don't have to be
vaccinated in the NFL.
But you do face all these
different set of rules that the
vaccinated players don't face.
- Yep.
- That sounds like what
the NBA is going to do.
It's stupid, it makes no sense.
It's no different than last year
when no one was vaccinated,
they're all in arena.
The coach is wearing
a mask for no reason.
He pulls it down every time
he wants to really be heard
and say anything important.
And it was just, it was
the masquerade theater
that we've been seeing.
- Yep.
- For the past 18 months
and they were doing it in NBA.
So a guy has to sit
in a different place
in the locker room.
Maybe he has to fly somewhere
differently on a plane.
But when you get on the court,
sweat and bump into each
other and slap high-five
and sit next to each
other on the bench,
sweaty as you wanna be.
That's all fine but when
we go in this locker room,
go sit over here because
you're not vaccinated.
It's just stupid.
- And I'm pretty sure you've
heard the same crazy rumors
that I've heard about when
the NBA was in the bubble,
right it was called the bubble
about all of the girls
that were getting
smuggled into the bubble.
Like it's not like these
people did not live
and I'm pretty sure
it didn't become
a COVID superspreader event.
- They, and I hope I'm not
cracking an inappropriate joke.
I don't, I can't but.
- That's all right.
This is YouTube,
you're all right.
- I'm not sure if you're aware
I'm not sure if you're aware
but I've talked to Dr.
Fauci about this personally.
The COVID virus cannot
live inside of a vagina
so when the women were
coming into the bubble
and you know, their
vagina's completely pure
and bacteria-free, COVID-free.
So that was perfectly
understandable and safe Dave.
- I'm just gonna
make note of that.
COVID cannot live in the vagina.
Okay, well we got our
promo out of you Whitlock.
Which, which sport.
You know we're talking
about the NBA now
but you mentioned the NFL.
Those seem to be the two
that are having this meltdown
and by the way, when you
mention the 7% increase,
I'm guessing that
the year before,
ratings were considerably more
down from the year before.
So it's sort of like a
not as great number right?
When they're talking about that.
But which sport
do you think has suffered
the most from all this?
It seems like the NBA to me
but I'm a little
out of the loop.
- It's hard for me to say
who has suffered the most.
I would probably argue,
I'm not gonna say sports.
NFL players have
suffered the most.
They allowed ownership to jam
a collective
bargaining agreement
and a salary cap
down their throat
before the TV deals were struck
and it was all under the excuse,
"Well COVID and you know
we're not gonna generate
"as much money."
And so even with all the money
the NFL players are making
and they're making a ton
compared to what they used to
and you know, guys
like Patrick Mahomes
and Dak Prescott are making
more than $40 million a year.
They're not making what they
could and should be making
if the COVID charade, if they
haven't damaged their business
with the George Floyd,
Colin Kaepernick,
let's piss off our
traditional fan base
and so I'm not sure if I'm
quite answering your question
but I would say over the course
of these five or six years,
the Kaepernick charade, George
Floyd charade and now COVID.
I don't think any sport
has been more damaged
than football players
and football and again,
I say that seeing the full
impact of what they've done
over the last five years
is going to play out
over the next 10 years.
Everybody right now
is you know, early on.
Football, I love it and
I'm going to these games
and it's screw Fauci.
We're partying and
acting like it's 1999.
When that dissipates
and when people are sitting
there because I'm telling,
week one of the NFL, I'm sitting
around watching football.
It's what I was built
in this life to do.
Watch football, talk about it.
Used to play a little
bit of it in college
but I'm just not as passionate
and eventually that
lack of passion,
once the thrill is
gone, the love is gone
and people understand like man,
I'm just really putting money
in some ungrateful
idiots' pockets.
You know what, I'm
tired of doing this
and I'm gonna spend time with
my wife and kids or family.
Imma go hunting,
imma go fishing.
There's other things
to do than watch people
that you don't respect play a
game that's been softened up
and dramatically changed.
The point I was arguing on
Wednesday on my show was like,
"The NFL has made a
bunch of decisions
"over the past 10 years
under Roger Goodell
"to satisfy its critics."
They've changed the rules
because of head trauma
and The New York Times
beat them up over CTE.
They allowed kneeling
because of Colin Kaepernick.
Because of George
Floyd they plastered
all these Marxist,
social justice slogans
all over everything.
It's, they're you know
and people will call me
a sexist pig but
they're decorating
their officiating crews
with women.
Their coaching
staffs with women.
Their executive
offices with women
and they're doing all
this to stay a step ahead
of the MeToo feminist movement
and they're just
piling on people
and I'm not saying look,
I know some women
who love football.
I know but they're
just pacifying people
whose hearts really
aren't in the game
and they're pacifying the people
the don't really love the game
and they're doing
nothing to satisfy me.
Their A1, ride or
die football fan.
What about me?
They just take me for granted
and eventually, guys like.
I'm gonna join guys like you
to just say you know what?
I got better things to do.
- So when they said
the NFL is gay,
did you have any clue as
to what they meant by that?
I mean they literally,
it was a commercial.
The NFL is gay.
I know a little bit about that
but I couldn't put
it all together.
- Dave, and I wanna
be respectful but.
I have to say there's
an alphabet mafia.
BLM, LGBTQ.
- Yeah I'm with ya.
- That's the mafia now and it's,
everything is being done
to say, don't attack me.
Black Lives Matter,
LGBT movement.
Don't attack me and
so they, you know,
the NFL is gonna say
I'm gay, I'm Marxist.
I'm gonna say the cops are out
randomly killing Black people.
I'm gonna say whatever
I think is necessary
to keep you off my
back and listen.
I grew up as an idiot.
In a football locker
room, as an athlete.
I can't say I was as
dumb as all the guys
I played sports with but
I'm certainly remember,
I'm 54 Dave.
I certainly remember in my era,
guys that were less
masculine than the standard
were mistreated and I am
really glad and thankful
that that has changed and we're
going a different direction
and everybody, that
kind of bullying
should not have
been tolerated then
and I'm glad we're
not tolerating it now
but I still think
there needs to be.
I can't be made to feel bad.
- Of course, of course.
- Because maybe I'm a little,
I got a little bit
more masculinity than
the normal person
and I'm just, football
is a masculine game.
It's not about your sexuality.
For someone like myself Dave,
I think we've all gone overboard
with our sexual identities
and we're all wearing
them on our sleeve
and it's like the first
thing we tell people.
I'm heterosexual and
boy do I like vaginas.
- Yeah, plus with the COVID
thing you told me before.
- Man I'm gay.
- You know?
- Yeah, it's like.
- Yeah.
- And Dave, the key
to saving this country
because I do believe
the country's at stake.
- I do, I'm with ya.
- We have to go back to hey,
I'm a Christian or
I'm an American.
Let that be your
initial identity
rather than your sexual identity
'cause I just don't think
what arouses us sexually
is all that important
and I'll say this as a Christian
and who was someone
who I think as a kid
and as a young person could
be accurately described
as homophobic and I regret that.
And I regret that as a Christian
because regardless of what
I think about homosexuality,
it's no different
for me as a Christian
than my promiscuity
outside of marriage.
So it was wrong to
try, us as Christians
that have these certain
beliefs to try to say our sin
isn't as bad as their sin.
And it's how we have.
We have created and I
blame us as Christians
for not being of tolerant
and more understanding.
We've created this backlash
and the alphabet mafia
and now I've seen people,
rather than
admitting their flaws
and then doing the right thing.
I see the NFL and
other sports leagues
bending over backwards
and doing things
that they really don't believe
to pacify social media,
the Twitter mob and
all the other people
that are allegedly on the
right side of history.
- Yeah, well Jason
let me say this.
As an American you get
no judgment from me
on any of your past judgments.
Let me just be very,
very clear about that.
Was it not Joe Namath who
said I was a gay Marxist?
Was it not him, wasn't
he a big gay Marxist
or am I confusing him
with somebody else?
- Joe (laughs) Joe
Namath did not say that.
- It wasn't Joe Namath?
- No.
- Wasn't Joe Namath.
Let me ask you, I'm
guessing you talk to players
in these leagues
probably on the DL.
But I have a friend or
two that's in the NBA
and I know that guys are
not happy about this.
They are not happy about
the politics in the sports.
They're not happy about
the influence of China.
There's a couple of people
that privately will
talk about this.
Not much, not many that
will talk about it publicly
and certainly most of the
coaches and Steve Kerr
and Popovich and
LeBron obviously.
Just loving on
China all day long.
But do you sense
players are angry
about all of this stuff too?
- I think where players
have gotten more aggressive
and it's still not
aggressive enough.
The vaccine push has really
pushed guys to the brink
and it's like this is a bridge
too far and I've bitten,
I've bit my tongue
and held my thoughts
on the political stuff and
everybody's sitting around
acting like America's the
most evil place on the planet.
They struggled with that
but they were able to.
But now it's about injecting
things into my body?
You're talking about the young,
some of the
youngest, healthiest,
most in shape people
on the planet.
The death rate, the damage
rate for COVID for these people
is virtually non-existent
and so I have seen
a growing discontent there
and I think it's helping
them realize like oh,
so when we accepted the kneeling
and the national anthem,
we never thought
it would get here
and now they're
starting to yeah.
That's why you gotta draw
a line in the sand on all
this stuff because eventually,
it is going to come for you.
And so, I do think there's a
lot of players that know like,
"Man, you know what I'm
able to do for family
"because of football
and basketball
"and America's
passion for sports?
"Why are we sitting up here
like we are the people,
"the most irate and
think America's evil?"
Yeah I've heard
from enough players,
particularly during
this vaccine thing
that it's going too far
and they know how
hypocritical it is.
They know that it's
driven by the players
who are addicted
to social media.
And you know, would rather
die than do anything
that didn't get 1000 likes
and 500 retweets and I,
but what most people
are doing and this is,
the players are following
the lead of Roger Goodell,
the executives in
the NFL, the owner.
Everybody's just trying
to do what's best for them
in the moment.
Roger Goodell, he doesn't wanna
do what's best for football.
He wants to do what's
best for him to survive
in a job that pays him
$40 million a year.
If he can squeeze six, 10
more years out of that.
And if football's in
a mess when he leaves,
that's someone else's
problem to fix.
He's made his money
and that's what players
mimicking the leadership they're
seeing from Roger Goodell,
mimicking the leadership
they see from ownership.
Hell if I can stick in
this another five, 10 years
and the value of this
franchise goes up,
I can sell and get out and
turn it over to someone else.
No one's doing what's best
for the games anymore.
It's just what's, there's
so much money at stake
and it's no different than
what we see in politics Dave.
All the politicians, they're
doing whatsever best.
So however long their
political career lasts,
they can make enough
money or set themselves up
to make enough money
on the other side.
Can I get the TV job as
MSNBC or CNN or Fox News?
Everybody's just doing
what's best for them.
No one, Dave I think
about this all the time.
John F. Kennedy in 1961,
"Ask not what your
country can do for you,
"ask what you can do
for your country."
We're so far away from that.
No one asks themselves that
question and if they did,
they would get thrown
out of politics.
Right, I always say it.
It's the 180 from what Bernie
and the left has been selling.
If he went on stage
and said that,
or any leftie went on
stage and said that,
they'd basically be strung up.
They say, "What can we give you?
"Hey let us know, we'll
give you some stuff."
So what would you do?
If you could take over.
I mean if you could take over
for Goodell or what is it,
Adam Silver at the NBA.
Give me like one or two
things that you might do
that would help the league
for longevity's sake
and not just the
immediacy of cashing out.
- What I would do Dave to be,
and this is particularly
as it relates to football
because football
is the most powerful
thing in popular culture.
It's the number one show
on five different television
networks by a mile
and so that makes it far more
powerful than Michael Jackson
or whatever entertainer.
"The Cosby Show" whatever was,
ever used to be
the most popular.
Nothing compares to the NFL.
Number one show on five
different TV networks.
And so my mentality as
it relates to the NFL,
as Commissioner would
be and I really would
and how can I use football
to help improve America?
That would be at the
top of my agenda.
And then what can I do
to serve my ownership
and put football in the
best position possible?
And so I would use
football as my bully pulpit
and I would take all of
the slings and arrows
and I would, there's
nothing we would do
that would be satisfying
to Black Lives Matter.
Football is about unity.
Every coach goes
into the locker room.
It don't matter
what color you are.
It don't matter what
neighborhood you came from.
It doesn't matter if
you're rural or a city kid.
Whatever, if your
parents were rich,
if your parents were poor.
We come together as a team.
My message as the NFL,
that's what we're about.
We're not oh, oh but oh.
Oh you're Black, there's a
special little set aside program
we have for you
and we have to make you
feel special and blah.
Football's never
been about that.
America and I don't
care what people say.
By Declaration of Independence
and by a Constitution.
I'm not talking about how
people actually ignored
what was in the Declaration
of Independence,
ignored what was in
the Constitution.
But America was set up that way.
To, I don't care
what color you are.
I don't care.
That's what America's intent is.
To operate the way sports
have traditionally operated.
That's why there was always
so much racial
progress in sports
and sports used to be a
leader in this country.
Jackie Robinson in 1947,
breaking the color barrier.
That's what inspired Dr. King
and the civil rights movements
of the 50s and 60s.
Sports used to be
a leader in America
and now we're
followers of big tech
and we're followers of
the globalist corporations
that are far more
worried about China
than they are about America.
And that's why I
think football's
in such a unique position.
The NFL doesn't need China
and it can still be a leader
and so, I would you know.
Go back and lean back
into what Pete Rozelle,
the greatest Commissioner
in all of sports,
what he did.
He attached football to
Americana and to patriotism
and he did all these thing.
'Cause that was their way
of undermining or surpassing
major league baseball.
And I would just lean back
into all those
traditional values
that made football great
and made it what it is
and I would stand firm and I,
I mean the difference
between me and Roger Goodell
is there's none of
these idiots at ESPN,
there's none of these idiots
at The New York Times,
none of them can
outtalk me on race.
They can't do it.
I've listened to them.
Hannah Nikole-Jones.
- Yeah.
- And the little
stupid 1619 Project.
I can go all day with
these guys and crush them.
Ta-Nehisi Coates that's
why they're all cowards.
They will not, these
people they won't come on
and engage with people
that disagree with them,
that can stand toe
to toe with them.
They won't be mesmerized
by their little word salads
and will just keep it real.
You couldn't, you get
one of these Black clowns
or liberal clowns
that go on TV and say,
"Oh my God the police
are doing this and that."
And I'm like, "Well what
hood have you been in?
"'Cause I can tell
you where I came from.
"I can tell you where my
daddy's business was in the hood
"and we spent no
time talking about.
"Oh my God, the police
may kill me tonight."
That's some bullshit
and I would call it out.
You're a little suburban,
Ivy League Negro
who's speculating about
what goes on in the hood.
I actually lived there.
I actually understand, I
still got family there.
It's not something
I just go visit
maybe at Thanksgiving
or whatever.
And so I would
clown suit the media
and anybody else who
challenged me on these issues.
I would still be
writing a column
as the Commissioner to the NFL
and anybody that
opened up their mouth
and wanted to give me any lip,
I'd just light 'em up in a
column and explain to them,
okay deal with that.
I've seen, Dave
I've seen people.
This is one of the craziest
things I saw in the media.
I saw a guy on TV
that told a story.
I think during the height
of the George Floyd
or one of these, Eric Garner.
One of these moments.
Went on TV and said
that he and his wife
had decided that they
would no longer let
their 18-year-old
son drive a car
because they were so
petrified of the police.
And I was just sitting
there and again.
This is the kind of.
If I was the Commissioner
of one of these sports,
I would clown suit this guy.
I would just go,
"Hold on man, you're
so afraid of the police
"that you're not gonna let
your Black son drive a car?
"Are you gonna let him go to a
party with other Black boys?"
Because statistically, his
chances of being killed
by somebody are
1000 times greater
by another 18-year-old
Black boy than the police.
So maybe you should pass a,
you can't run around
with Black boys.
And then I, now go ahead
and respond to that.
I would, and they wouldn't have.
They would have nothing to say.
America could see
these are clowns,
these are people that are
just saying shit on TV
to draw attention to themselves.
To make sure that the
cheques come in from MSNBC,
China, Nike, whoever.
But this isn't the truth and so
if I was a
Commissioner of the NFL
I'd just stand on
truth and I would.
But Roger Goodell, he's not
equipped for this argument
or this time and you
know, ownership scare.
But at some point, Dave,
men are gonna have
to be men again
and men that understand
how good this country
has been to us and our families
are gonna have to stand
up and fight this fight
and quit hiding.
It's one of the main reasons
I left corporate media
'cause I you know, I wanted
to get in the fight for real.
I want the gloves off and
let's pick up these muskets
and let's mow down
some of these idiots
that are trying to
tear this country down.
- So I'm guessing you're
not getting any calls
from good ol' Joy-Ann Reid
over at MSNBC for
these conversations?
- I wish she would call me Dave
because what I would like to,
I'd like to introduce
her to a beautician
who could get her to
settle on a hairstyle
because every time you
turn on that damn TV,
she got a new
hairstyle, new wig.
She's culturally appropriated
from every race on the
planet with her hairstyle.
One day it's Wilma Runo Wilma.
Who is it?
- Flintstone, Flintstone.
- Is it Wilma,
Flintstone, Wilma Flintsone.
- Wilmma Flintstone.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
- What was,
Barney Rubble?
- Rubble, rubble.
- Yeah but.
- Yeah.
- His,
you just never know
from day to day
who's she gonna culturally
appropriate from
hairstyle to hairstyle
and then I mean,
and she's one of the
biggest phonies on TV.
Her old blogs are what
she really thinks.
This woman was raised in
a church just like me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- She's on TV lying,
pretending that she's
some kind of leftist
and it's all to
collect a cheque.
And those are the real sellouts.
Those are the people selling
out what they really believe
for money and then
they sit around
and they wanna cut Tim Scott.
They want Carly (beep)
or (beep) and all this.
So yeah, no I won't be
getting a call from Joy Reid.
- Yeah and I,
you know not that Twitter is
much of a barometer of anything
other than the general hate
of the world but you know,
I see what people say to you.
We talked about it last time.
You'll make a political
comment or a sports
or a societal comment
and then the things
that they will say to
you as a Black man,
the supposedly tolerant people.
It's just extraordinary
and it just never ends.
- Dave, I've said
it for a long time
and I've got some
awesome liberal friends.
Awesome.
- Yeah.
- But I have always faced
discrimination, bigotry,
jealousy from white liberals.
That's been the
story of my career.
That there have been some
that have tremendous to me
and I've written about them,
called them out by
name but overall,
the white liberal, how
they feel comfortable
helping Black people is like,
"Oh can I bend over and
help you out poor Negro
"and then when I help you out,
"make sure that you
put it on your resume
"that I helped you out.
"I'm gonna tell everybody
and you know what?
"For me helping you out, never
say a word I disagree with.
"'Cause if you do."
- Yeah, exactly.
- "You've sold me out
"and you're an
ungrateful person."
And I just, I don't wanna
generalize but you know,
about conservatives
but what conservatives
have generally done
in this business
as it relates to me is like,
"Oh man, how can we make money?"
And that's, that's it.
It's like, what you need?
How can we make money?
With the liberal, it's hey man
you gotta pledge allegiance
to everything that I believe in
and then we can make some money
but you better thank me every
day when you come in here
that I allowed you to make
this money and I just, wow.
That's what I think Dave.
- No I got ya, I got ya.
You'll appreciate
this couple days ago
'cause I told you I don't
watch the new games anymore.
I watch these old
games on YouTube
and I was watching
the 92 finals.
You know that's the
Jordan shrug year
and they're interviewing
Clyde the Glide,
I've got a ball signed from
him right behind me here
and they start asking him
about race out of nowhere
and you may remember,
Clyde never had an
opinion on anything.
He never really
commented on anything.
It wasn't his thing and
they keep trying to get him
to comment on race
and then they go,
it's a white
interviewer by the way.
He's still in the biz,
I'll tell you who he is after.
It's not, we don't
need to throw him
under the bus right now.
And he goes, he goes,
"Well Jordan, you know
with all this success
"and all this influence,
"shouldn't you be doing
more to make sure racism
"doesn't exist in America
and everything else?"
And Clyde who never said
anything really interesting
outside of basketball he goes,
"You know he's a
basketball player.
"He's working on his craft,
he's not a politician."
And I was so freaking
relieved to hear it
that this guy who I
love 'cause of his skill
said something sensible and
that was 1992, 30 years ago.
You could say something
sensible and you wouldn't be,
now he would be called a sellout
for saying that basically.
- And potentially
run out of the NBA.
He would definitely
get a suspension.
- Yeah.
- They'd come up with
some reason to suspend him.
How dare you say that racism
isn't the number one thing
and that Michael Jordan
who's a basketball player
must take a position on that.
What Clyde said there
is 1000% sensible.
Look, it's so hard to
compete at the level
that Jordan, Clyde Drexler
and these guys did.
If people think
that when Jordan's
at the height of his career,
that he's also studying
up on geopolitical issues
and domestic issues,
the guy just had
some self awareness.
Like I'm gonna stay in my lane.
I'm a basketball
player right now,
why don't y'all go
ask the politicians
or the historians or
activists or whatever.
Why are you asking me
as a basketball player?
And it's one of
those selfish things
that we in the media
did because we all.
This generation, the generation
of sports journalists
that didn't get to
cover Muhammad Ali.
Didn't get to cover the
impact of the Vietnam War
and the civil rights
movement on America.
Those of us that
didn't, we wanna redo it
and we wanna turn LeBron
James into Muhammad Ali
and I've said this
many, many times.
LeBron James is a
basketball player.
He's not that smart,
listen to him talk.
Go read his Twitter
feed, his Instagram.
He can barely spell
but y'all think
this guy is some kind
of thought leader,
public intellectual, whatever.
And then the number one
thing 'cause I you know,
his lack of grammar
and all that,
I could almost deal with that
but what the media
won't deal with
is that Muhammad Ali,
whether we like the
Nation of Islam or not.
He was connected and
controlled by a religious sect
and Elijah Muhammad, Malcolm X,
whether we like them or
not, very smart people.
Ahead of the curve,
they control.
Muhammad Ali said what
they told him to say
and did what they told
him to do at that time.
LeBron James ain't
connected to nobody but Nike
and Phil Knight.
Phil Knight is not Elijah
Muhammad or Malcolm X.
And so whose, whose
advice, Adam Mendelsohn
and I know Adam Mendelsohn,
the PR guy that works around.
But he ain't Malcolm
X or Elijah Muhammad.
Expecting any of
these, these athletes
can barely keep up
with they baby mamas.
How the hell they gonna
keep up what's going on
in the rest of the world?
It's, we keep putting them
in this position and we keep,
"Oh who gonna be the
next Muhammad Ali?"
And we have to accept,
those days are gone.
The athletes today make
millions of dollars,
live in gated communities
next to people who
look like Dave Rubin
and they're not in the hood,
they're not connected
to the working class,
Black Americans
or White Americans
the way they used to be.
These are the elites, they've
been let into the club.
That's why they go through
these little rituals
of putting dresses on
like Russell Westbrook
and they go through
these humiliation rituals
so they can be
let into the club.
They're not speaking for the
working class person anymore.
They're speaking for Nike,
they're speaking for China,
they're speaking for
their pocketbooks.
We need to cut it
out, asking these guys
to do things they're
incapable of doing.
I almost feel sorry for them.
It's like, it would almost
be like, if somebody asked,
"Hey spend the
night at McDonald's
"and never eat a double
Filet-O-Fish sandwich."
It's not gonna happen Dave,
it's not gonna happen.
- I do, I do like
the Filet-O-Fish.
That tartar sauce, it's tangy.
- Yeah.
- It's delicious.
I wanna talk to you about tech
and a couple of other things
but is there anything else
going on in the sports
world that's just
got you going at the moment?
- I think we got it.
I think.
- We got the big stuff,
all right.
- Yeah, I think we got it.
- So the tech stuff, let's
do a little bit of that
'cause you years ago,
now everybody's sorta like,
"Oh Twitter's evil and
it's what's causing
"all of this chaos."
And you know I just
did this month off
and what I kept thinking was,
"I don't mind doing videos.
"I don't being on,
posting pictures of food.
"It's something about Twitter
"that is making
everything melt down."
How do you feel about the
state of tech at the moment
and the way that we
are being manipulated
whether we know it or not?
- I think that Twitter's
grip on public discourse
is leading America and the
world straight to hell.
It has so dumbed
down the conversation
and it's so reliant on
spectacle and Twitter,
it's not just Twitter but
TikTok, Reels on Instagram.
Every, we, our phones
have so much stuff
loaded into them that's
supposed to keep us,
our attention away from what's
really going on to spectacle.
In hey, who's dancing on TikTok?
Whose butt looks the
best on Instagram?
Who has said the most racially
divisive thing on Twitter?
Who has spotted an alleged Karen
who has mistreated
a Black birdwatcher?
We are so hyper-focused on
things that don't matter
and we're not smart
enough to say,
"Hey man, the puppet masters
want us focused on things
"that don't matter and we keep
giving them what they want
"and they keep getting
to do whatever they."
They're printing as
much money as they want,
they're selling us out to
China and God know who else.
They're abandoning Americans
over in Afghanistan.
They, they're labeling a protest
at the Capitol an insurrection
and we're going for it
because Twitter said so
and there's this viral video
and if you don't hop oh my God,
you're questioning
whether or not
you should take the vaccine?
Oh my God, we'll suspend
you from Twitter.
They are in control
of the conversation.
They're dictating what's
appropriate conversation,
what's appropriate
thoughts to have.
The whole point,
particularly as a journalist.
Question everything.
That's the job of a journalist.
I was told in college, it
was one of the cliches,
mantras of journalism.
If your mother says she loves
you, get a second opinion.
That's what journalists
are supposed to do.
Twitter, Facebook, all
of them now are not,
there's some things
you can't question.
If, and it's crazy.
Dave, the vaccine in my opinion
is meant for overweight
people 50 and above like me.
That's who it's meant for.
No one should be
forcing a 25-year-old
in great physical condition
or even if they're
in moderate or bad,
they shouldn't be forcing a
25-year-old to take a vaccine
that's meant for me and people
should be able to say that
over social media
without a Twitter mob
or getting suspended
or Twitter posting
oh this is misinformation.
Of course the same things
that Jason Whitlock should do,
of course Cole Beasley
or Lamar Jackson
or one of these perfectly
healthy NFL players,
they should do the
exact same thing.
It's, that's never been true.
That's never what
America's been about.
Twitter is the
home of groupthink
and the home of control.
It's where the media go.
Every dumb fake narrative
that the mainstream media,
corporate media comes up with,
Twitter is its
justification for.
Well it's trending over Twitter.
You know, LeBron said Black
men are getting hunted
every time they go out.
Look, that's the way Black
people believe and it,
and that's the other thing Dave.
It's, I don't know what
this relates directly,
I'm sure it does relate
directly to big tech
but we're building a war Dave
based off of
feelings and desires.
Oh if someone feels this way,
we better make rules to back
them up and so you know what?,
If people feel that the
police are killing Black men,
even though the
stats say otherwise,
well they feel that way.
So let's change the laws,
let's change the rules.
Let's pretend like
it's a crisis.
That we're gonna step over
1000 dead bodies in Chicago
and New York and
Baltimore and everyone,
but this George Floyd
body, now that's special.
We gotta do something about it.
Yes we have just stepped
across a 12-year-old kid
that was slaughtered
by gang violence,
a four-year-old little
girl that got a,
caught a stray bullet
from gang violence.
We're gonna step over all those
and make sure we
address this one thing.
Twitter justifies that.
Twitter, the algorithms
and it's all rigged up
in my opinion to
make us think that
George Floyd is reality,
an everyday reality
and some 14-year-old kid
getting slaughtered in gang,
well that's lightening.
That's getting
struck by lightening,
that never happens, ignore that.
- Right, right or
if you talk about
how many people got shot in
Chicago, you're the racist
for bringing it up.
That's the other one.
- Very racist.
Because Dave,
I'll just say this.
- It's very racist.
- What you don't
understand there,
if we ignore those deaths
in Chicago, they go away.
Those bodies, it's
almost like Jesus.
They're resurrected
three days later
and they come back
to their communities,
changed men and individuals
and they turn water into wine.
- Were you shocked at all?
I suspect not,
over what happened
over the last couple weeks
with the Larry Elder campaign
in California?
I mean, the media treated
him absolutely horribly.
LA Times, he's a Black
white supremacist.
Joe Biden on stage
refusing to say his name,
calling him a Trump clone.
The guy was born
in South Central,
his dad was a janitor.
Barack Obama doing
a hit video on him
without even mentioning
his name again.
Did any of that shock you?
I mean when you
see a Black person
who happens to fall somewhat
in your political space,
the abuse, I assume
you're beyond shock
at this point right?
- Yeah, I'm not shocked.
What happened to
Larry Elder though,
what shocked me was my
initial gut reaction,
it was like, well Larry Elder
ain't got no shot at it.
They're not gonna recall Newsom
and then when I saw the
LA Times and everybody
viciously going after him,
I was like oh my God, he
must have a chance to win.
There's no, they've
unleashed the hounds
and it made me take his
campaign more seriously.
I thought, you didn't reference
but the woman, the white
woman in the gorilla mask.
- Yeah.
- That threw an egg at him.
Swung at his security guy
and hit him in the face.
Someone ran up behind
that same security guy
and kicked him in the rear end.
Dave, the only thing we
can analogize that to
is what we saw in
the 1950s and 60s
and what Black people
sitting at lunch counters
and people treating
them horrendously.
That's what we were.
This white woman put
on a gorilla mask
and threw an egg at
this man and these,
the hypocrisy of the left
to not be apocalyptic
about this,
to be completely out.
There's not.
- No I know, I know.
It's completely, trust me.
I was traveling with him.
To say it's exasperating,
it's not even the right word.
It's like how dare you guys?
Doesn't make CNN,
doesn't make MSNBC,
doesn't make the New York Times.
- It.
- But LA Times,
LA Times managed to
manipulate a photo of him
so it looked like he
was hitting a woman
as they were claiming there
was an incident in Venice.
An incident where a gorilla
woman threw an egg at him.
That's what these people do.
- I don't, I'm trying to think
of what the racial equivalent
has been in terms
of racial politics
over the last few years.
Have we seen anybody
else treated this way?
And for corporate
media to ignore it?
Is mind-boggling
and it's, it's why
Trump supporters believe
the media is the
enemy of the people
because the media
not being a referee,
being a fair arbiter is what
creates the racial divide
and animosity that's running
wild in this country.
When there are people,
we've turned half the
country into the voiceless.
Because if, and it's not
just Trump supporters.
It's people like
me, who my crime
is not hating Trump.
- Yep.
- I'm not a Trump supporter.
I just don't hate him.
- Yep.
- I don't really, politics
ain't really my thing.
I don't vote for
anybody, I never have.
My crime is oh you
don't hate Trump
and so those of us that
either support Trump
or don't hate Trump,
we have no voice
in corporate media.
You know I guess Fox News is,
but we're so
overwhelmed by the rest
and I look at the people that
are supposed to be journalists
and the outlets that
claim they're journalists
and the people that think
they're doing all the,
I'm on the right
side of history.
No you're not,
again you may write,
you may have Hannah Nikole-Jones
and the New York Times
write a fake history that,
but you're not on the
right side of history.
We're supposed, the
media should be out,
virtually every day.
What is the frustration,
why are people turning to Trump?
Why did they turn to
a reality TV star?
What are we doing wrong?
What are politicians
not offering the people
that Trump is filling that void?
We should be explaining that
and giving these people a voice
and making them feel
important and like,
represented in this country.
And then they
would start looking
for different solutions but
if Trump's their only option,
they're gonna take it
out of desperation.
- Well said.
All right, I got one more for ya
'cause I know this
was on your mind
'cause this is what you
had reached out to me about
about a couple of weeks
ago and I've been talking
a bit about Bill Maher
lately on the show.
You know me, I was a
big liberal, big leftie.
I can't quite say that anymore.
Actually in reality I'm
probably still a liberal
but we don't really
exist anymore
but your argument I
think is that Bill,
at this point is probably
just a conservative.
Something to that effect.
It's an argument I've kind of
been making for awhile too.
That on all of the
important things,
he no longer is a leftie
but he's part of the
Hollywood machine
and what frustrates me is
I always see all the people
on the right crediting him every
time he says something sane
but then at the same time,
he will keep telling people
to vote for Adam Schiff
and vote for Joe Biden
and vote in all of the people
that are destroying everything.
I don't wanna lead
you too much there
so I'll just hand it to you.
- Yeah.
- What do we do
with these liberals?
What do we do with these people?
- Well one of the things
I suggested Dave is
and I don't know
how I feel about it.
I just kind of threw
it out as a question.
And it ties in nicely to
what I was just saying.
Is Bill Maher is, the fig leaf
he's covering himself with
is Trump.
Is his allegiance to the
Democratic Party at this point
seems to be totally
based on hatred of Trump
and any time you argue
with somebody on the left,
they avoid getting into a
substantive discussion with you
by playing the Trump
card I like to call it.
And they just talk about Trump
and so I've asked myself
the question like,
if Trump backed away and said,
"You know what, I'm
exiting politics.
"I'm gonna help Ron
DeSantis, Josh Hawley,
"I don't know, whoever."
Someone else, if
Trump backed away
would that like be
pulling the chair
out from underneath the left
and making them
fall on their ass
and make them have
to actually deal
with the things
that they're doing?
And if they had to actually deal
with the things they were doing
and they weren't allowed to say,
"Trump, Trump,
Trump, Trump, Trump."
'Cause the thing that
put me over the top was
Bill Maher is on his show
and he's got some woman on
from the LA Times.
She's some kind of
Washington correspondent
and he's talking about how,
like oh my God, Joe Biden
just screwed up Afghanistan.
There's no way it could've
been handled any worse
and he tosses to this
woman and she goes,
"Well it could be worse.
"Trump could be."
And I was just like,
"Well he ain't there for one."
And Bill Maher disagreed.
- Yeah.
- He was like what no,
it couldn't have
been worse for Trump.
Just cut it out.
Trump is the only
thing they have
and I'm just wondering
if it was taken away,
would they collapse on top
of their illogic and idiocy?
- What you're saying
in that regard,
that he's kind of there
because in that case
he didn't say it could
be worse with Trump.
I think I would probably
argue that back in the day
they used to tell you that
George W. Bush was a racist
and evil and all of those
things and let's not forget,
Mitt Romney hated women,
he had a binder of women.
Like they always got somebody.
Trump is just the
special somebody
but for me it's like get
to the end of the road man.
Just get to the end of the road.
The conservatives
aren't coming for you.
You may disagree with
them on abortion,
you may disagree
with them on religion
but they're not coming for you.
The other guys are coming
for everything you hold dear.
- And so the thing I
wanted to ask you is,
do you see similarities
between yourself and Bill Maher
in terms of,
has Bill Maher been red pilled?
Is he going down the path
where eventually he's
gonna have to admit
that he's no longer
what he used to be?
- Well let's do this.
I'll give you the 30
second answer here
and then we'll do the
rest of it on your show,
fair enough?
- Fair enough.
- All right so the 30
second answer is yes,
I believe he's basically
been fully red pilled.
It's so obvious to
me it's ridiculous
but he's in Hollywood,
he's a mainstay of 30 years.
Standard bearer of leftism
and he's got a career
and he has a legacy that
he's trying to protect
and I think he knows he's
in his last couple years
of this run and he's going,
"Man, would I flip
at this point?
"And I've been calling
all of these people
"backwards idiots for being
believers and I hate religion
"and blah blah blah.
"And suddenly they're the
ones that are protecting me?"
He's at the end
of what I would say liberalism
has wrought unfortunately.
Purely secular liberalism
and he's up against that
and yet his intellect
has been red pilled.
So how do you negotiate between
your red-pilled intellect
and the reality of your
life at a certain age?
That would be my
sort of Psych 101
but we can unpack that
further on your show.
- Yeah I think he's
in a tough spot
because it's not
even just Hollywood.
He'd have to give up
probably a lot of his friends
and his social circle.
- Oh yeah.
- And you know, he's,
you don't wanna do that.
- Well Jason I'm pretty sure,
I'm pretty sure you know
just as well as I know
that when you give up
some of those people,
you actually get better friends
on the other side usually.
All right, I know
that's the case for me
and I guess for
you too probably.
- You get friends that are
actually really with you
and they're not with
you over politics.
They're with you
because you know,
content of your
character and your heart.
- Whitlock, you are fearless
and I will be a guest on
Fearless in the near future.
I'm away next week, I'm
away for a couple days
but then I will do the show.
We'll pick up right
where we left off and.
- I'm gonna wait for Bill Maher
to say something
controversial again
and then I'm gonna
put the request in
and Dave, I gotta
be honest with you.
I put a lot of pressure on you.
I just gave you my A plus
material for an hour straight
and so you gotta
return the favor.
- I will caffinate
heavily that day.
All right, the show
is Fearless, BlazeTV.
Whitlock, I'll see you soon.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist
and if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out the full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.